Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmische angelegenheiten mein name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zum neuen jahr zwanzig zwanzig das die erste sendung
die ich in diesem jahr aufnehme,
der reigen lustiger themen abfolgen geht hier natürlich weiter und heute blicken wir auf ja,
kleine unbekannte objekte im weltall und warum die denn eigentlich so interessant sind konkret geht es um asteroiden wir hatten ja schon mal eine sendung wo es spezifisch um asteroiden und kometen,
als solche ging heute allerdings schon wieder drauf aus der perspektive,
einer mission konkret der zwei mission,
ja und dazu bin ich nach bremen gefahren zum institut für raumfahrttechnik des,
dr und begrüße meine gesprächspartnerin ramiro schönen guten tag frau sie sind hier,
als.
Jetzt muss ich kurz nochmal nachdenken leiterin der mascot mission im rahmen der hayabusa zwei mission aufgestellt das ist richtig ne.
Ja das ist richtig.
Und zwei ist eine premiere japanische mission zu einem asteroiden darüber werden wir gleich noch viel sprechen,
zu beginn würd mich natürlich erst mal interessieren wie sie eigentlich zu raumfahrt gekommen sind warum.
Ja
Hätte doch auch viele andere schöne sachen machen können im leben.
Das stimmt ja,
ich bin von der ausbildung her bin ich physikerin ich habe physik studiert schon aus überzeugung natürlich ähm.
Manche machen das auch wenn ihr nichts besseres eingefallen ist.
Ich muss zugeben ich habe gewürfelt.
Einzige okay zwischen.
Medizin und physik ja genau aber letztendlich habe ich mich doch dann für die physik entschieden,
und,
mich auf astrophysik konzentriert habe meine doktorarbeit dann im bereich kometen,
habe ich absolviert und bin dann durch mehrere stationen dann an das den er hier in bremen angekommen.
Wo war das studium ursprünglich.
Also meine doktorarbeit habe ich in bern absolviert und bin danach dann zuerst.
Nach holland genau bei der esa war ich dann und nach drei jahren bei den holländern habe ich dann gedacht möchte ich wieder zurück nach deutschland.
Und dann fiel die wahl auf bremen.
Dann fiel die wahl auf bremen es gab ein neues institut das institut für raumfahrt systeme hieß es oder heißt es immer doch.
Ich habe kaum fahrtechnik gesagt ne raumfahrt systeme ist.
Raumfahrt systeme genau und mich hat das überzeugt beim interview wurde mir gesagt hier wird noch hands on alles gemacht hier dürfen sie ihre hand auf richtige hardware legen.
Nicht nur studieren nicht nur powerpoint präsentation.
Was wird denn das institut für raumfahrt systeme aufgestellt also was ist denn hier sozusagen eigentlich der zentrale bereich an dem gearbeitet wird hier.
Zwanzig haben wir drei säulen.
Fangen wir immer dazu das eine ist dass wir analysieren wir analysieren haben theme es umfasst nicht nur kleine
roboter auf kleinen körpern sondern es kann auch sein satelliten,
wir haben hier auch eine satellitenbild von gestartet letztes jahre gruppen ähm nein gestartet ist es sogar das jahr davor,
war sozusagen inbetriebnahme dann letztes jahr.
Muss man erstmal den jahreswechsel.
Genau eben ich bin noch in zwotausendneunzehn.
Da sind wir alle.
Ja und dann wir haben auch wir forschen auch an orbitalstation systemen,
auch diese dinge analysieren wir und das ist die systeme löse dann tun wir auch ähm technologien entwickeln.
Das da haben wir die an denen wir forschen oder auch jeans systeme an denen wir forschen hier im institut.
Das ist was.
Das sind alles systeme die mit dem herz sozusagen eine satelliten oder eines landes zu tun hat ähm es handelt sich hierbei um den bordcomputer
um die kommunikation die antennen auch um das power system,
all diese systeme die dann sozusagen.
Essentiell sind.
Essenziell sind genau.
Jens hier steht dann für guidance navigation control also die ganze steuerung orientierung im raum etcetera.
Ja
Ja das heißt hier wird richtig erfunden sozusagen gebaut und gelötet.
Genau.
Das sind die einzelnen technologien aber wir machen dann auch wir entwickeln natürlich dann auch das system selber das heißt wir analysieren nicht nur die machbarkeit zum beispiel sondern wir entwickeln dann an den systemen
dazu gehört ein messgerät ist ein system es besteht aus vielen subsystemen oder auch,
kropes das hat lieb oder auch andere systeme die hier entwickelt werden und äh da haben wir das system engineering sozusagen hier im haus als eine der wichtigsten kompetenzen,
die projektentwicklung.
Sollte man auch nicht unerwähnt lassen nebenan ist ja das zahn mit dem schönen fall turm das heißt wenn man dann was schönes gebaut hat dann kann man dann auch gleich schon kaputt machen und aus hoher höhe fallen lassen.
Ja nicht nur beim zahn wir haben hier auch ein labor gebäude dort ähm unterlaufen die ganze systeme dann die tests die ganzen qualifikations test um sozusagen das system dann startklar zu machen für die mission denn.
So ein kleines sozusagen so ein.
Es ist ein kleines ein testzentrum.
Aber der fall turm wird dann auch genutzt.
Der fall turm wird genutzt wenn es relevant sein sollte für das projekt das war es für messgerät da haben wir dann die separation des landes vom mutterschiff haben wir dort getestet,
um zu schauen ob das auch funktioniert weil das eines der schlimmsten dinge die passieren kann nicht nur für uns sondern auch für unsere japanischen kollegen ist dass sie wieder,
ja zurück zur erde mitfliegen mit wieder mitbringen müssten wenn die separation nicht geklappt hat oder das,
hängt so zusammen dann noch irgendwo dran.
Irgendwas kann immer schief gehen ja.
Genau ja.
Also messgerät ist der länder der also einer der länder die in dieser hayabusa zwei mission,
zum einsatz gekommen sind da werden wir gleich nochmal im detail drauf eingehen.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage was macht eigentlich asteroiden mission so interessant was was verfolgt die wissenschaft derzeit für ziele warum,
kriegen diese mission den zuspruch und die finanzierung und die durchführung derzeit was was sind die unbekannten die man jetzt hier ausforschen möchte.
Also es gibt meiner meinung nach drei große beweggründe warum man asteroiden unter unbedingt studieren möchte,
und das eine ist
der wissenschaftliche ansatz wir möchten natürlich etwas mehr wissen oder wir wollen natürlich verstehen wie das sonnensystem aufgebaut ist und dazu gehören asteroiden als eines der elementaren bausteine also die asteroiden,
sind vielleicht bauteile der planeten gewesen aber
sind letztendlich dann als asteroiden geblieben und solche dinge möchte man natürlich diese dieses rätsel der entwicklung unseres sonnensystems da erhoffen wir natürlich durch
mehr informationen zu den asteroiden zu ihrer zusammensetzung zu wo der chemischen wie auch der,
physikalischen dann mehr informationen bekommen um dann auch die ganze entstehung des sonnensystems zu verstehen das ist,
der wissenschaftliche teil der zweite aspekt ist dass asteroiden natürlich auch eine gefahr darstellen für die erde.
Gab in der vergangenheit asteroiden einschläge auf der erde aber nicht nur auf der erde auch auf sämtlichen planeten oder auch mondmäßig sie das sehen sie hier die,
muss man ja nur die genau muss man ja nur auf die oberfläche schauen und das könnte natürlich eine gefahr sein wenn da ein asteroid einschlagen sollte er muss nicht mal groß sein
also es kann auch nur ein teil eines asteroiden sein und da habe ich auch kürzlich einen vortrag dazu gehört es
kann ja weniger als ein meter sein und trotzdem schon sehr sehr viel schaden,
und wir haben das auch am beispiel dieses dieses chilli einschlagen gesehen wo ein meteorit eingeschlagen ist ein fireball oder feuerball,
und da sind auch innerhalb dieser stadt sind gab es unglaublich viele schäden.
Das war im februar zwanzig dreizehn also jetzt sieben jahre her knapp da gab es ja dann auch schon viele videos,
vor allem weil so viele immer mit kameras in ihren autos herumgefahren sind und gab,
zerplatzte scheiben entsprechende schäden und bedrohung dadurch merkte vor allem auch diese immense sprengkraft wie so eine vergleichsweise kleiner
astrid also man sagt ja dann meteor wenn er runterkommt hat einfach durch das auftreffen auf die atmosphäre durch die hitze bildung wenn dann alles auseinander fliegt das jetzt einfach energien frei die man sich sitzt so
erstmal gar nicht vorstellen kann und es gibt ja auch ganz klassische das tun goshka,
ereignis wird glaube ich auch einem asteroiden zugeschrieben dass jetzt hundert jahre her ein bisschen mehr,
offensichtlich ein ein sehr viel größeres objekt heruntergekommen ist und wälder platt gemacht hat etcetera.
So ist das und wir wollen nicht hier über die dinosaurier reden.
Wobei die hätten da sicherlich auch noch was sozusagen.
Ja gut also astrid können eine gefahr sein ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen so eine abstrakte geschichte da sagen wir die politiker wahrscheinlich so ach jetzt kommt die wissenschaftler wieder hier mit ihrer gefahr und so die wollen ja nur mehr geld haben,
aber es ist vielleicht unwahrscheinlich aber ich denke wenn man diese risiko abschätzung macht mit so ja es mag vielleicht,
unwahrscheinlich sein aber wenn's passiert dann ist gleich so richtig unangenehm.
So ist das und es geht glaube ich auch hier vor allem vor allem um die fragestellung wie früh
können wir denn solche möglichen gefahren schon erkennen dass sie unwahrscheinlich sind ich glaube dass
uns natürlich hoffnung ein bisschen besser zu schlafen aber wenn es denn passieren sollte muss man zu früh wie möglich agieren,
asteroiden einschläge die je nachdem wie klein diese teile sind umso später können sie entdeckt,
und dies ist auch dieses frühwarnsystem ist dann so wichtig und da muss man eben verstehen wie,
groß wie klein wie sind sie zusammengesetzt solche fragestellungen muss man dann beantworten.
Hm
Das war ja hier auch schon mehrfach thema weil bei raum zeit vielleicht mal kurzer verweis für leute die ganz gerne auch mal zurück
hören ausgabe einundsiebzig hatte ich mich mit rüdiger jenen konkret über die frage der asteroiden abwehr unterhalten was da so für kataloge geführt werden wie die risiken so eingeschätzt werden wir da noch mehr hören möchte,
kann da mal rein horchen ich denke vor allem ist es aber die die wissenschaftliche frage die natürlich jetzt
diese mission drückt und die frage der gefahrenabwehr ist so quasi nochmal so ein abfallprodukt weil umso besser man das kennt umso
näher man dran war umso mehr man darüber weiß wie sind die aufgebaut wie muss man die dann handhaben wenn's denn vielleicht wirklich mal so ein problem wird,
das sind alles immer so ganz
breite erkenntnisse die man dabei gewinnen kann aber vor allem ist es eben so diese diese kernvorschläge jung die die die grundlagenforschung dieses verstehen wollen
wo kommt denn das jetzt hier weil ich meine asturien gibt's ja eine menge masterinnen gürtel gibt's keine ahnung ob es eine sinnvolle schätzung gibt wie viele objekte dort unterwegs sind da sind die eigentlich auch,
schön dass die weit weg sind aber ab und zu kommt ja dann doch nochmal einer vorbei und diese kategorie dieser erdnahen
asteroiden die tun uns ja jetzt auch den gefallen dass sie dann eben ab und zu auch mal so nah rankommen dass man eben die gelegenheit nutzen kann auch mal vorbei zu fliegen.
Genau man kann natürlich mit einem geringen delta wie das ist mehr oder weniger die aufwands abschätzung in der raumfahrt dann ähm zu diesem erdnahen asteroiden fliegen.
Also die geschwindigkeit relative geschwindigkeit des asteroiden zu erde.
Zur erde genau und das ist natürlich für erdnähe asteroiden
bedeutet das auch dass wir weniger treibstoff brauchen um dorthin zu kommen und das macht natürlich auch so eine mission dann günstiger umso mehr man treibstoff
braucht umso mehr muss man mitschleppen umso mehr masse hat man und umso mehr kostet dann auch diese mission.
Raketen sind erforderlich etcetera.
Ja
Was war denn so die ersten missionen die wirklich jetzt zu asteroiden geflogen sind erfolgreich und die uns dann schon erste erkenntnisse gebracht haben.
Die ersten missionen also ich würde sagen eine der bedeutenden asteroiden mission ist die schuhmaker mission,
der nasa die ist zum asteroiden geflogen hat den kartografiert und,
dann als der treibstoff dann zu ende war auch auf dem asteroiden gelandet mehr oder weniger ziemlich sanft.
Eine andere mission war die mission,
die berühmte bruscetta mission bevor sie zum kometen schulhof grass gelangt ist flug sie an zwei asteroiden vorbei,
ein astrid ist und dann restauriert lucia da gab's ja auch spektakuläre bilder,
vor allem dann von lucia sehr hoch aufgelöstes bilder die eine oberfläche zeigten die wirklich also,
unterschiedliche ich würde sagen merkmale auf der oberfläche die ja,
unterschiedliche geologische merkmale hatte und die.
War da so so abwechslungsreich also ich meine wenn ich da so auf das bild draufschaue siehst du ein paar krater und ansonsten viel grau.
Ich glaube das sieht man meistens.
Ja aber was was könnte man daraus lesen.
Da muss ich aber nochmal die bilder genau anschauen aber es gab soweit ich mich erinnern kann doch,
viel mehr an aktivitäten auf der oberfläche zu erkennen als man gedacht,
weil normalerweise geht man davon aus es handelt sich hier um tote körper sozusagen im himmel da passiert,
aber soweit ich das von den kollegen mitbekommen habe ähm ist es so dass es erstmal unterschiedliche oberflächen gibt mit unterschiedlichen merkmalen,
auch dass es zu einem art gefälle gekommen ist zu einer bewegung der oberfläche,
aber was da genau passt dann als interpretation dann rausgekommen ist müsste ich nochmal nachschauen.
Okay aber auf jeden fall war das ein erkenntnis gewinnen auch wenn man jetzt nicht drauf gelandet ist einfach das genauer hinschauen und vor allem eben diese hochauflösende kameras die
bei rosetta an bord waren und sind auch noch andere dinge newtonmeter et cetera zum einsatz gekommen alles was irgendwie,
man sich leisten konnte in dem moment dafür strom zu verbrauchen.
Ja
genau ja und dann haben wir natürlich die mission da muss man immer unterscheiden viele sagen dazu heia buße eins aber es ist an sich die haie mission.
Muss man doch nicht dass eine zweite gibt.
Damals wusste man nicht dass es eine zweite gibt,
die hat ja zum ersten mal auch asteroiden proben zurückgebracht zu erde und das war schon spektakulär so etwas gab's davor noch nicht.
Schauen wir doch nochmal ein bisschen auf diese erste mission weil ja im prinzip die grundlage der zweiten mission ist ganz klar also ist zweitausenddrei gestartet die mission war dann sieben jahre später oder acht jahre später zwanzig zehn,
abgeschlossen seine mission wie auch jetzt der nachfolger primär von von der japanischen,
raumfahrt organisation geführt von der nasa weiß man irgendwie viel,
von der esa weiß man in der öffentlichkeit meist schon weniger wer raum zeit hört was eine menge über die elsa ist so ein bisschen,
sommer in unserem kosmos ein wenig unbekannter worauf worauf spezialisieren sich die japaner was was ist so ihr ansatz und,
können sie irgendwas dazu sagen,
ein anderer stil herrscht oder ob ob es eigentlich nur dasselbe in grün ist was dort gemacht wird wie muss man darauf blicken auf die axa.
Also,
ich selber hatte auch vorher natürlich nur von der mission gehört wenn man sich das so anschaut dann denkt man sich wirklich von der jan hat man wenig man fragt sich natürlich auch
liegt das auch einfach nur daran dass man die japanischen zeiten nicht lesen konnte einfach,
ist ein bisschen schwieriger als bei der nase nach zu blättern da sieht man da holt man sich viel mehr an inhalten raus als bei der jagd und auch ich glaube dass in den letzten jahren die jacke
sehr,
sich auch darum bemüht auch dem internationalen publikum etwas zu bieten da sieht man auch schon jetzt wenn man sozusagen die englischen zeiten sieht und das war wahrscheinlich vorher nicht gewesen.
Als ich dann am,
mit der zwei mission angefangen habe oder angefangen habe da involviert zu sein wurde mir dann auch eine richtige roadmap vorgestellt also die hatten einen plan,
die wussten sozusagen genau also das was man vielleicht nicht lesen kann weil man vielleicht nicht die information,
verstehen kann oder bekommen kann das hatte sich dann in diesem vortrag dann wirklich gezeigt,
materialisieren also sie hatten eine roadmap und es war geplant dass es eine hayabusa mission gibt
und eine zwei mission und dass die jagd gerade im bereich der kleinen körper gerne sagen wir mal,
alle asteroid klassen besuchen möchte.
Also sie selbstgewählte spezialisierung einfach weil man gesehen hat das machen die anderen nicht so oder hat die das besonders interessiert oder gibt's da irgendwas in der japanischen raumfahrt tradition was so darauf hingeführt hat.
Da müsste ich natürlich noch viel mehr nachfragen was jetzt
wirklich die hintergründe sind wissenschaftlich kann ich mir vorstellen dass es natürlich sehr interessant ist wie gesagt ich meine kleine körper asteroiden sie schlagen nicht nur auf die erde ein sie sind nicht nur
teil des sonnensystems sondern vielleicht auch dieses puzzlestück was sozusagen wasser oder organische
elemente auf unsere erde gebracht hat aufgrund dessen dass sie auch auf die erde,
aufgeschlagen sind das ist der wissenschaftliche teil 'ne andere an andere grund kann auch sein dass gerade durch die untersuchung von erdnahen asteroiden was technologisch,
machbare ist für ich möchte nicht sagen wenig geld aber letztendlich doch machbare als wenn man wirklich dann in die weiten unendlichen,
welten des weltalls fliegt das ist natürlich vielleicht machbare so kleine.
Kleine.
Mission zu kleinen körpern zu entwickeln und ich glaube das spielt vieles mit,
was die beweggründe der unterstützt hat dann zu sagen okay wir spezialisieren uns auf kleine körper auf asteroiden,
gesehen davon das andere ist vielleicht weniger gemacht haben.
Ja okay dann schauen wir doch mal was die busse mission so losgetreten hat also es wurde das lied gebaut.
Das ziel war der astrid.
Also auch noch mit japanischen namen haben die dir dann auch gefunden sozusagen und benannt vorher und dann gesagt so da muss man jetzt mal hin weil das war ja dann wahrscheinlich auch so ein ordner astrid der vielleicht noch gar nicht so lange bekannt war vorher.
Weiß ich nicht ob der nicht schon seinen namen hatte bevor die mission dann den asteroiden besucht hat bei rico ist es wirklich so gewesen dass er ruhig gut dann danach benannt wurde dann nachdem die mission schon,
gestartet ist.
Aha also war ist ja der begründer des japanischen weltraumprogramm.
Ja
Nicht ganz nicht irgendein name.
Nicht irgendein name genau und wenn man weiß wie asteroiden benannt werden dass man sucht sich natürlich auch die leute aus die dann etwas für die raumfahrt getan.
Ich bin grad mal geschaut also das tatsächlich erst achtundneunzig entdeckt worden also fünf jahre bevor.
Ja
Gestartet hat das natürlich lässt schon mal drauf schließen dass man.
Eigentlich dabei war eine mission zu planen aber noch gar nicht genau wusste wo es hingehen soll,
das kommt ja gerade in mode habe ich so den eindruck dass man sehr dynamisch reagiert nicht wahr dass bei so zum beispiel,
habe ich ja hier auch neulich bei raum zeit ein gespräch darüber geführt,
also sollte es sein und die mission wurde dann zweitausenddrei gestartet und ist ja auch.
Nicht ohne probleme gelaufen wenn ich das richtig sehe es gab.
Bis zum asteroiden ging das noch ganz gut am asteroiden fingen dann meine meinung.
Schon so das vorher schon sonnenstürme ein problem war und schon so den ganzen.
Die elektronik oder.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau was ist richtig sehr sind irgendwie solarpanel so ein bisschen unter beschuss gekommen oder die energieversorgung sodass nicht ganz so schnell geflogen werden konnte wie es ursprünglich geplant war.
Ja das kann sein davon hab ich nicht.
Aber es hat auf jeden fall geklappt da sind dort gekommen und da kam ja auch schon eine erste landeten zum einsatz die auch glaube ich in japan entwickelt wurde.
Wie man ja genau das hätte der erste rover sein sollen der auf einem asteroiden landen sollte,
aber leider hat es nicht geklappt,
er ist verloren gegangen in dem sinne dass die separation natürlich geklappt hat aber die landung nicht.
Timing nicht hingehauen hat.
Nicht weil das timing nicht hingehauen hat sondern weil das gravitations feld nicht richtig bestimmt wurde,
oder nicht richtig bestimmt werden konnte und entsprechend ist minerva dann wieder also wieder,
es hat ja nicht die oberfläche irgendwie berührt sondern es ist vorbei geflogen und ist dann verloren gegangen.
Weil das das ist ja sozusagen das problem man hat es mit so einem kleinen objekt zu tun.
Dass man bestenfalls ein teleskop als kleinen grauen punkt sieht und man kann es halt lange beobachten und dann sieht man so ah okay alles klar eben war da noch da jetzt ist er da bahn bestimmung geschwindigkeit
alles kein problem das kriegt man relativ genau hin so dass man da eben auch hinfliegen kann aber wenn man erstmal da ist dann ist ja so der unterschied mit dann bist du jetzt einen kilometer im durchmesser oder vielleicht dann doch
zwei man weiß es nicht genau und das hat ja damals auch immer noch nicht genau sagen kann was weiß ich drin sind so und so masse reich weil,
klar vielleicht hört man's bei einem mal bestimmt aber es heißt ja nicht dass der andere dann genauso ist muss man das alles vor ort,
eigentlich erst feststellen das heißt man muss dort messungen vornehmen,
und überhaupt erstmal bestimmen ok mit was haben wir es denn jetzt hier zu tun und dann quasi seine landeplätze daran anpassen.
So ist das und auch weil es so kleine körper sind haben sich sehr.
Unregelmäßige formen das heißt das gravitationswellen kann sich ja auch variieren über den asteroiden hinweg,
am anfang nimmt man natürlich einen runden asteroiden an aber wenn man da ankommt und gerade bei edeka war ist das ja eher mehr so ein länglicher asteroid da kann sich auch das gravitationswellen sich dann auch verändern je nachdem wo man
absetzen möchte und wenn man das nicht genau bestimmt und auch dann vielleicht nicht die richtige,
erreichen kann dann passiert es dass dann ähm die separation sozusagen schiefgehen kann.
Ja also wie ungewöhnlich dass sein kann hat man ja auch bei bei der rosetta mission gesehen damit humor mango der siebenundsechzig p der auch,
sehr überraschend aussah,
zwei aneinander geklebt e teile vermutlich weiß ich nicht genau wie weit man da mit der forschung schon ist aber sah zumindest jetzt nicht aus als wäre es so aus einem ei gepellt worden und dementsprechend verteilt sich natürlich dann die gravitation extrem kompliziert und es macht auch die,
schwer.
Über den körper verteilt es sich und je nachdem wie man sozusagen die vorbeiflüge
plant kann man auch entweder gut oder ein bisschen mit schlechterer auflösung die gravitation bestimmen rosetta war in
im orbit,
machte der mission ist leichter die gravitation des ganzen körper im laufe der zeit zu bestimmen bei der mission ist es so dass das mutterschiff,
ich sage immer das mutterschiff dazu dann in einer konstanten distanz zum asteroiden mitgeflogen ist das nennt man huber ring,
dadurch rotiert der astrid natürlich immer unter dem raumschiff aber.
Man kriegt nur eine achse.
Man bekommt wahrscheinlich nur eine achse je nachdem in welcher position man isst und da braucht man zeit natürlich um wirklich dann das ganze gesamte gravitationswellen zu bestimmen und,
wenn aber die separation des lenders auch zeitkritisch sein könnte oder weil man man möchte natürlich immer ein länder absetzen bevor man sample weil man möchte natürlich zuerst mal die oberflächen definition erstmal,
hinbekommen,
bevor man dann sample dann ist das immer so eine kombination zwischen gutes timing wann haben wir denn die daten wann sind sie gut genug und.
Können wir dann endlich mal loslegen.
Dann können wir denn eigentlich dann los.
Weil jeder tag der mission dieses länger dauert erhöht natürlich das risiko dass irgendwas ausfällt.
Irgendetwas ausfallen.
Irgendwann ist ja auch die zeit abgelaufen und man muss dann auch wieder los.
Was zurückbringen will und das war ja bei der fall trotzdem hat das ja dann funktioniert das heißt auch wenn der länder nicht funktioniert hat und man durch ihn keine weiteren informationen bekommen konnte,
ist dann das mutterschiff ist.
Ich hätte jetzt fast gesagt auf crashkurs gekommen aber es ist ja sozusagen der hat sich ja direkt auf diesen asteroiden herabgesetzt.
Ja genau hat sich sogar hingelegt für eine für eine kurze zeit.
Ja und dann und dann gegraben oder vorher was reingeschossen wie wie läuft das dann ab.
Die proben name läuft durch einen touchdown go verfahren nennen wir das heir booster hat,
horn ein sample horn wird er genannt das ist ja so ein langer trichter,
das mutterschiff nähert sich dem asteroiden sehr langsam und sobald dieser trichter die oberfläche berührt,
ein signal zurückgeschickt das heißt es gibt kontakt und dann wird ein projektil auf die oberfläche geschossen und der aufgewirbelten staub,
aufgenommen und in kleinen resources dann.
Aufgefangen genau und die werden dann versiegelt und.
Im mutterschiff und dann später sollten sie dann wieder auf der erde landen und so geht das normalerweise und so wird es auch geplant aber gerade dieser,
es ist manchmal schwierig zu bekommen und eines der der manöver glaube ich der mission ist ja auch schief gelaufen weil es hießt,
bei dem ersten bei der ersten probenentnahmen das kontakt da ist und es wurde sozusagen die probe entnommen aber letztendlich war es nicht der fall gewesen und,
manche unserer japanischen kollegen haben dann gesagt da müssen wir noch ein bisschen aufpassen vielleicht war gab es ja irgendwie eine.
Wolke die dadrüber flog dich sozusagen dann diesen trigger mechanismus aktiviert hat und ähm ja was das gehört ja dazu zu exploration es gab einen zweiten versuch ja.
Auch mutig weil ich mein sich so mal so eben,
da so in kuss position zu gehen sozusagen sich so nah an so einem objekt dran zu wagen hat ja eine ganze menge andere,
probleme weil ich nehme an die solarpanelen sind dann immer noch komplett ausgefahren man muss
also mit so einem fragilen gerät an so eine alles andere als homogene struktur heran fahren da kontakt suchen und dann sich wieder verabschieden,
na ja das ist auf jeden fall schon mal ein risiko für sich.
Ja aber bei toka weiß noch leichter bei rico war es schwieriger weil die hatte einen,
bauchbereich es auch bei es sieht es so aus als ob es sich um ein astronom,
ein asteroid handelt der aus zwei teilen besteht und dieser mittlere bereich der war sehr sehr eben und entsprechend,
hatte man natürlich sich auch darauf konzentriert dann die ebene fläche zu nehmen für das sample wobei wenn es natürlich
karate reicher ist wenn es die struktur viel viel steiniger ist ist es natürlich schwieriger und das war bei ruhig der fall.
So um vielleicht mal hayabusa abzuschließen also diese proben wurden dann entnommen und versiegelt viel war's nicht ich glaube so ein gramm oder sowas und größer viel weniger.
Nein viel weniger viel viel weniger ja genau.
So in der größenordnung von mikrogramm oder.
Milligramm genau.
Aber das hat man dann nach hause gebracht.
Hat man nach hause gebracht ja.
Im richtigen moment hat man sich dann quasi von den frieden wieder entfernt ich nehme an wenn so die erde einmal rum war man reist ja im anflug quasi erstmal mit der erde mit holt sich vielleicht noch irgendwo schwung,
und dann,
man hinter dem asteroiden hinterher und versucht ihn langsam einzuholen aber nicht zu überholen also man muss sozusagen immer langsamer werden rosetta hat's ja ähnlich gemacht mit dem kometen,
und dann ist man dort und dann muss man aber auch irgendwie wieder die energie haben.
Sozusagen um dann.
Sich wieder der erde anzunähern.
Ja so ist das und gerade bei mir war es ja so dass sie eine verzögerung ja bekommen haben weil es mit der brummt entnahme nicht zu,
geklappt hat und es letztendlich haben sie dann auch,
das in kauf genommen dann mit einer verspätung von drei jahren dann wieder auf die erde zurückzukommen sie hat,
natürlich auch auf dem heimweg dann noch andere probleme da sind auch ihre rasters dann ausgefallen und eines nach dem anderen.
Dem motto was schiefgehen kann geht auch schief.
Geht auch schief ja aber das schiff war hat sich doch irgendwie berappelten und,
ist noch geschafft die proben dann abzusetzen.
Absetzen heißt das quasi so eine kleine kapsel wo die proben drin sind.
Die wurde separiert.
Genau über der erde dann sozusagen runter geworfen.
Ja genau ja und ähm,
die kapsel wird sozusagen separiert fällt dann auf die erde landete auf das ist in australien und zwei ist dann entsprechend dann sozusagen in der atmosphäre verglüht.
Diese kapsel war wahrscheinlich nicht besonders groß.
Die ist auch nicht klein ich glaube sie ist ja jetzt zeige ich es ihnen zu.
So ein halber meter.
So ein halber meter ja genau.
Weil ja auch eine ganze menge hitze sozusagen hitzeschild mit dabei sein müssen wenn der eintritt in die atmosphäre stattfindet aber es ist nicht extrem schwierig,
so ein rück wurf so zuverlässig zu machen mal klar man kann das irgendwie alles berechnen aber es ist ja sehr viele unwegbarkeiten drin wenn ihr so ein stück metall auf die oberfläche trifft und,
thermische dynamiken sich da voll entfalten alles was die physikalische gesetze so hergeben oder muss man das ding ja auch noch finden.
Ja das stimmt.
Wie macht man denn das also wie stellt man denn sicher dass man es auch.
Wiederfindet.
Und wie stell mal vor allem sicher dass irgendwo runterkommt wo man auch eine chance hat es wiederzufinden.
Ja
Deswegen australien wegen großer.
Wegen der großen fläche genau dass es auch kein kollateralen schaden irgendwie dann birgt das ist auch irgendwie zivilisation fällt das wäre ja auch ein no-go,
ich gebe zu jetzt müsste ich nachgucken aber ich würde mich nicht wundern wenn es auch irgendwie in art prinzip gibt der sozusagen ein peilsender.
Peilsender sozusagen.
Der den leuten sagen dass wo man so suchen muss ja.
Sonst wäre im vergleich die nadel im heuhaufen gerade.
Genau.
Okay hat aber so auf jeden fall funktioniert und auch wenn einiges schief gegangen ist das ist ja dann auch eigentlich immer gut für so eine mission also es ist doof für die mission in dem moment aber es ist halt,
gut weil man einfach so viel draus lernen kann und weiß so ah okay wer hat ein triebwerk probleme werden softwareprobleme gravitations messung probleme wir hatten probleme mit sonnenstürmen wir hatten probleme der datenübertragung wir hatten probleme unserer lage regelung alles mögliche
da müssen wir jetzt nochmal beigehen und jetzt machen wir das irgendwie alles besser und dann,
habe ich ja vorhin schon erwähnt gab es ja relativ schnell die entscheidung so okay alles klar in unserem großen plan gehen wir jetzt auch den nächsten schritt und mach nochmal busser zwei,
was hat man denn aus diesem proben,
herausziehen konnten also haben denn diese proben diese paar milligramm,
zeug die man da eingefangen hat schon auch irgendein versprechen eingelöst oder hat es einfach nur lust auf mehr gemacht oder war das dann zu wenig so hart doof hat,
hat nicht gereicht wir brauchen noch mehr von dem zeug was was war so die primäre motivation im prinzip dasselbe nochmal zu machen.
Im prinzip dasselbe nochmal zu machen wie gesagt,
es gibt ja eine roadmap das heißt es war klar dass sie auch eine zweite mission starten werden es war war das ein typ asteroid,
hier ist ein asteroid,
der unterschied ist das typ asteroiden dabei handelt es sich um steinige asteroiden die deren zusammensetzung wahrscheinlich aus,
material besteht aus der oli wien und aus silikat,
gestein in vor allem und das hat sich auch bewahrheitet.
Wenn man sich die proben angeschaut hat bei.
Das wusste man vorher eigentlich nur aus der spektralanalyse.
Genau auf den.
Das ding im teleskop angeschaut.
Hat dann die spektral des spektrums angeschaut und entsprechend hat man dann werden dann die asteroiden dann in in typen oder in klassen unterteilt und wenn das spektrum viel
chillie karten aufweist dann oder an an mineralien dann klassifiziert man sozusagen dann diese asteroiden in die typ
asteroiden und die steinigen asteroiden sind zwar interessant aber wenn es um die wissenschaftliche frage geht
wie ist denn das leben entstanden auf der erde wie ist wasser
auf die erde gekommen wie sind die komplexen moleküle auf die erde gekommen und eines der hypothesen ist ja,
ruinen oder kometen einschläge so sind asteroiden die eben kohlenstoff verbindungen interessanter die vielleicht organische elemente aufweisen und
das sind dann eher die asteroiden die ein spektrum aufweisen die vielleicht mehr in diese richtung gehen also.
Die nennen wir das sind die asteroiden also die die mit kohlenstoff bindungen es gibt auch p
typ asteroiden da werden auch dann eher mehr organische elemente vermutet und es gibt auch asteroiden die sind sogar die darf man gar nicht anfliegen
weil das planet harry protection so,
streng ist dass da auch die vorkehrungen einfach viel komplexer sind.
Weil man da so viel wertvolles drauf erwähnt dass einfach mal so hinfliegen und rein reinfliegen und drin rumschippern ist einfach mal geht gar nicht.
Man also die die darf man gar nicht mehr anfliegen genau ja oder.
Sozusagen so dass dass das space privataudienz und naturschutzgebiet so.
Genau und.
Bei handelt es sich eben um einen typ und das war auch das nächste ziel der jagd gewesen zu sagen okay jetzt haben wir ein typ asteroiden untersucht aber jetzt wollen wir einen typ steroiden untersuchen und schauen,
da diese verbindungen gibt es da wasser vorkommen,
was wir sozusagen dann verbinden können mit dem mit der frage der entstehung des lebens auf der erde und ja also es war,
dementsprechend für die jagd klar dass sie so eine mission starten das ist so schnell ging ist wahrscheinlich auch dem hype,
geschuldet der natürlich dann in japan groß war das war die erste japanische mission die eine probe zurückgeführt hat oder überhaupt das ist so gut angekommen dass die jagd gedacht hat dann eben,
so schnell wie möglich legen wir noch einen nach ja.
Ich habe gerade mal geguckt ja also von diesen kategorien gibt's ja eine ganze reihe
also ist ja mit c und davor ist es ja noch lange nicht getan hier gibt's a b c d e,
f g und dann geht's nicht mit haar weiter pr vr x aber die typen die man kohlenstoff sind die häufigsten astrid,
das heißt man wollte auch mal sich das angucken was quasi so der klassiker ist und der.
Der klassiker ist ja.
Und für leute die gerne astrid mining machen die würden natürlich gerne zu den typ zu reden gehen fliegen.
Weil da sind die tollen sachen.
Ja genau.
Ok also die metallischen.
Die metallischen genau und man erhofft sich die seltenen erden darauf zu finden ob das so ist ja.
Zuletzt wir werden sehen gut also zwei wurde dann konzipiert und das ziel war klar rio go.
Sollte angeflogen werden und ich habe.
Ich habe da mal geguckt es gibt ja eine eine schöne geschichte also auch dieser name ist nicht so ohne weiteres gewählt worden sondern das ganze ist so eine japanische
legende folklore wo ein,
zusammen ein ein mensch eine schildkröte rettet und dafür belohnt wird mit einer reise zu einem unter wasser drachen palast,
um von dort dann mit einer mysteriösen schachtel zurückzukehren die ja.
Irgendwas enthält auf jeden fall,
öffnet er sie dann am schluss auch und wird aber so ein bisschen bestraft weil also zurückkehrt hat er festgestellt dass irgendwie hundert jahre unterwegs war aber offensichtlich nicht gealtert ist.
Erst also die schachtel dann öffnet als bestrafung wird ihm das alter dann wieder.
Wieder.
Gerechnet das fand ich jetzt wirklich ein extrem
passenden namen oder beziehungsweise schöne geschichte wunderbar dazu passt war ja dieses ganze reisen im weltall ja dann auch immer so viel mit relativität und zeit zu tun hat also im prinzip bisher in dieser japanischen legenden geschichte die ganze raum zeit verzerrung.
Hallo.
Perfekt.
Perfekt genau ja aber wir mussten lange mit einem anderen namen arbeiten also ruhig go ist.
Weil es noch kein gab.
Weil es noch kein gab also wir in unseren dokumenten hieß roku sehr lange neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig und
erst als es zum launch sozusagen gekommen ist hat ja dann der asteroid auch seinen namen bekommen oder bestätigt bekommen weil das muss ja auch immer durch das ganze prozedere der
und der internet.
Julian.
Genau und dann durften wir oder mussten wir dann unsere dokumente entsprechenden aktualisieren ja.
Haben sich auf jeden fall schönen namen ausgedacht wie war denn das jetzt überhaupt mit der zusammenarbeit ist ja auch mal wieder
ungewöhnliches im weltraum aber in diesem fall während glaube ich die erste mission noch sehr viel japan zentriert war also die ganze entwicklung satellite et cetera auch die länder technik,
komplett in japan entwickelt wurde hat man sich jetzt hier sehr viel breiter aufgestellt unter anderem das drk mit ins boot genommen wer war denn noch mit dabei.
Also dabei international ist es vor allem über messgerät dass der und die knäste,
hat.
Also die franzosen.
Die franzosen genau und hatte auch noch nasa im im team weil die haben dann die deep-space antennen gestellt,
ja genau aber auch hayabusa hätte,
internationaler sein sollen und es ist auch wahrscheinlich der grund warum es geht dann so geworden ist wie messgerät ist weil auch bei hayabusa hätte es,
zusätzlich zu den minerva rovers hätte es rover noch untergebracht werden sollen aber der gps rover wurde im laufe der zeit dann wieder,
entfernt.
Weil die nasa sich zurückgezogen hat aus.
Die nasa hat sich zurückgezogen hat und entsprechend war dann dieser platz frei und da zwei busse eins mehr oder minder,
baugleich sind bis auf,
einige wenige verbesserungen war eben auch diese charity da die für einen möglichen europäischen länder zur verfügung gestellt wurde.
Also der slot vor quasi die sonne dann drin ist und rausgeschubst wird.
Genau und.
Und dann fiel die wahl aus ddr.
Dann fiel die wahl auf das drk das der grund war dass wir nein plank immer der grund war dass,
die jagd und die elsa eine mission geplant haben das ist die marco polo mission gewesen und die marco polo mission hätte zu einem asteroiden auffliegen sollen und,
da wurde ein länder vorgeschlagen,
vom drk für die mission die marco marco polo mission und diese marco polo mission hätte sein sollen auch mit der jackson
dann ist aber marco polo nicht ausgewählt worden und,
dann sind die japanischen kollegen dann auf uns zugekommen und haben dann gemeint ja,
ihr seid jetzt so zu sagen habt ihr ja so eine studie gemacht und wenn das jetzt nicht klappt mit marco polo warum wollt ihr den nicht auch etwas studieren für uns,
weil wir werden auf jeden fall eine folge mission machen die zwei mission und es wäre doch schön wir haben.
Bisschen platz zufällig und wenn ihr etwas entwickeln könnt was genau darauf passt dann würden wir euch mit.
Und zu dem zeitpunkt war ja wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehen der timeline auch rosetta schon lange in planung oder sogar schon unterwegs.
In planung ja.
Das heißt so länder ist jetzt auch so ein thema beim ddr und auch nochmal ganz interessant finde ich,
also marco polo ist vorgeschlagen worden ist da nicht genommen worden
aber das heißt ja nicht dass er nicht schon relativ viel intelligenz darauf verwendet wurde wie denn das so ist das steht jetzt nicht nur so auf ein blatt papier macht man sich auch wirklich intensiv über alle komponenten sehr viel gedanken,
muss auch ein bisschen frustrierend sein eigentlich für wissenschaftler wenn man da so viel zeit und energie investiert sagst du ja das wäre jetzt mal eine super mission und dann hast du die politik in sachen an die kein geld,
oder und dann,
hat man dann so ein jahr vielleicht an so einem so einem plan gearbeitet aber es ist halt nicht unbedingt immer alles für die katz weil kann ja sein dann kommen japanischen kaiser und sagen.
Können wir ja mal zusammenkommen so war es jetzt auf jeden fall und dann ging's los sozusagen und da waren sie dann von anfang an mit dabei.
Dann waren wir von anfang an mit dabei ja und nichtsdestotrotz weiß,
wir hatten natürlich die marco polo studie durchgeführt aber die anforderungen von der jagd war doch.
Bisschen anders ich würde sagen das ist untertrieben,
weil hatte ja nur diesen diesen platz zur verfügung und,
das war
zwanzig mal zwanzig mal dreißig zentimeter und das ist ja nicht viel größer als eine schuhbox und sie meinten sie haben zehn kilogramm zur verfügung und.
Wir sollten mal etwas entwickeln.
Macht mal was damit ja.
Genau was da reinpasst ja.
Und was also okay,
und was wusste man über den asteroiden zu dem zeitpunkt schon weil das ist ja dann sozusagen auch eine größe mit der man arbeiten muss wenn man jetzt dinge konzipiert und dinge größenordnungsmäßigen versucht einzuschätzen.
Also man wusste wenig also man weiß natürlich den spektral typ das ist ein typ asteroid ist also kann man sich vorstellen was man was einen erwartet aber,
auch weiß man
mehr oder weniger die größe wenn man die größe nicht wüsste dann wäre wäre es noch schwieriger aber wir wussten dass circa ein kilometer als durchmesser hat
und was wichtig natürlich für die haie busse zwei mission ist die bahn elemente solche dinge sind bekannt aber wie,
wirklich der asteroid aussieht das wussten wir nicht und wir waren auch sehr sehr überrascht also ihnen dann gesehen haben dann letztendlich vom nahen und,
man tut sozusagen dann seine technologie sein system,
gegen diese unbekannte dann entwickeln und es ist schwierig,
man muss natürlich dann sich überlegen wie man ein system entwickeln kann dass mit.
Im unbekannten terrain trotzdem agieren kann und man versucht natürlich so viel gesagt,
in unserem engineering sagen wir dann auch so viel,
business also dem system zu geben wie möglich also dass das
system so robust ist wie möglich so dass es auch dann operieren und leben kann wenn das terrain doch ganz anders aussieht
als das was wir erwartet haben.
Dann sprechen wir noch mal so ein bisschen in die mission rein also zweitausenddrei war dann der staat wie lange war der athlet unterwegs.
Zweitausenddrei zweitausenddrei war.
Zweitausendvierzehn ich weiß bei der ersten mission solange es ja noch nicht nein zweitausendvierzehn war der staat,
und dann muss er erstmal wieder ein komplexer pfad gefunden werden weil man kann ja nicht direkt hin sonst fliegt man einfach dran vorbei.
Nein ja.
Sondern wie vorhin schon erwähnt man muss irgendwie ein pfad finden wie man sich mit der richtigen beschleunigung,
hinter den flugbahn des asteroiden einreihen kann was war hier erforderlich jetzt um das zu erreichen.
Ein östringen bei und dann viel viel steuerung der der rasters.
Wie macht man denn eines fing weil wenn man jetzt sowieso erstmal also wo wo ist denn dann quasi die sonne das erste mal hingeschickt worden also überholt,
man die erde komplett oder fällt man zurück also wie macht man den zwingen bei wenn man jetzt die ganze zeit daneben und hat einfach den normalen orbit ausgenutzt oder muss man sich nicht erstmal,
entfernen um irgendwie so einen zwing bei auch richtig durchführen zu können.
Also man muss sich entfernt natürlich von der erde um da.
Sich sich dann sozusagen,
in das richtige orbit zu bewegen und was ausgenutzt wurde ist natürlich dass man den impuls hat den man dadurch bekommt mit dem erdarbeiten,
das heißt man geht dann schon mal um die sonne herum und es ist ähnlich wie mit der,
wie die erde auch und dann zu gegebenen zeiten ähm,
ist es ja so dass wenn man sozusagen mit der erde sich um die sonne dreht,
ähnlichen orbit dann kommt man dann auch wieder an der erde vorbei und bekommt dadurch dann den schub,
und danach hat dann zwei ein weiteren schub gemacht um sich dann aus diesem erdogan,
sich herauszubewegen und sich dann dem anzunähern,
und das hat dann auch noch circa zwei jahre gedauert,
bis er sozusagen also bis zwei dann ähm den asteroiden eingeholt hat.
An sich ist das ist der orbit,
von zwei sehr straight forward also es ist sozusagen einmal mit der erde um die sonne dann erst ring bei und dann ging es direkt an in den asteroiden.
Mit rein.
Wie nah ist denn dieser astrid also man sagt jetzt erdnahen weil er ja überhaupt erst mal vorbeikommt,
es ist ja nicht so dass er die ganze zeit um die alle herum kreis sondern hat ja selber noch sehr viel größeren arbeit der glaube ich weiß nicht sogar noch bis zur venus geht glaube ich im inneren und nach außen noch ein bisschen weiter wahrscheinlich.
Also jetzt auch nicht so dass wir jetzt alle naselang bei uns vorbeikommt sondern es ist eigentlich ein vergleichsweise seltenes ereignis da muss man dann eben auch.
Nicht nur das richtige timing habe um dahin zu fliegen sondern sozusagen auch zum richtigen zeitpunkt starten wenn man zu spät ist dann.
Dann hätten wir nämlich noch warten müssen so ist das man muss natürlich das richtige timing haben für den launch und da gibt es auch nur bestimmte lounge windows ja die müssen wir dann abwarten.
Also dezember zwanzig vierzehn ging's los dezember fünfzehn war dieser swing bei und dann hat's noch bis juni zwanzig achtzehn gedauert bis man dann da war.
Zwei runden hat es nochmal gedreht.
Und dann konnte man ja das erste mal schauen okay was haben wir denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich und sie meinte ja gerade sie waren ja alle sehr überrascht wovon.
Von der form des asteroiden weil es sieht aus als ob es sich um ja ich würde sagen zwei pyramiden sich handelt die aufeinander,
gesetzt.
Diamant form so.
Diamanten form die asteroiden forscher nennen das top shape
das ist die eine sache aber die andere sache ist natürlich dann umso näher wir kamen haben wir dann gemerkt dass die oberfläche sehr sehr,
grob war dass es fast,
nirgendwo ist auf dem asteroiden irgendwie ein ein terrain gibt welches,
eben ist und das macht natürlich die landung auf dem asteroiden viel gefährlicher.
Man muss ja dann auch noch die gravitation vermessen also das kann ja noch mit dazu.
Ja das kam noch dazu aber das,
zwei dieses mal sehr sehr gut gemacht sie haben mehrere messungen durchgeführt sie sind näher ran gegangen um dann sozusagen dann auch,
die anziehung sozusagen des asteroiden dann zu messen zum space craft und haben das sehr sehr gut ermitteln können.
Aber es gab keinen orbit.
Es gab kein.
Wurde nicht um den asteroiden herumgeflogen.
Nein es ist wieder ein hufe prinzip gewesen das heißt zwei fliegt dann mit einer distanz von zwanzig kilometer neben dem asteroiden.
Aber halt nicht auf der rotations achse des asteroiden sondern so ein bisschen versetzt sodass also quasi unter unter dem eigenen blickwinkel sich das ding die ganze zeit dreht.
So ist das ja
für die messungen wie zum beispiel die gravitation hat sich dann busse zwei der oberfläche immer und immer wieder angenähert es gibt dann diese
dieses manöver sozusagen dazu dienen dann nicht nur die oberfläche besser.
Zu charakterisieren sondern dann auch die separation und die die probenentnahmen dann
zu trainieren.
So das ist jetzt so quasi diese abtastphase man schaut erstmal womit er es denn zu tun das hat glaube ich so drei monate gedauert oder so.
Das hat drei monate gedauert bis dann minerva zuerst und danach messgerät gelandet sind.
Jetzt müssen wir mal was zu diesem line-up da sagen was damit geflogen ist weil es gab ja nicht nur ein länder sondern es gab vier länder oder drei.
Vier inklusive messgerät sind dass wir.
Ich glaube das ist eine lessons learned gewesen von oder von der hayabusa mission für das ähm,
man anstatt einem minerva auch zwei fliegen kann oder so viele wie möglich die mina war,
besteht aus eins eins und es handelt sich mehr oder weniger um.
Gleiche rovers die sind identisch und das sind auch die die dann im september zweitausend achtzehn auf rücken gelandet sind und die minerva zwei,
da haben wir nicht so viel davon gehört dass es auch so dass es mir so eine art,
technologie demo war die man dann mitgenommen hat wenn sie denn.
Passt und wenn sie klappt dann klappt sie und das war glaube ich,
anders wie die minerva ein rovers vom design her aus.
Ich glaube die einsam waren so so so zylinder artige länder und zwei war irgendwie so ein prisma artiges gerät also da hat man quasi so ein bisschen technologie test gemacht,
so wir nehmen mal das was wir beim letzten mal leider nicht haben landen können guck mal ob das funktioniert aber falls es vielleicht
doch nicht so eine gute idee war das design haben wir ja noch ein anderes und dann kann man das eben auch gleich vor ort vergleichen weil es super gelegenheit weil man kommt ja jetzt nicht alle naselang am asteroiden vorbei,
und wenn's passt und wenn man das in die pilot noch mit rein bekommt die dinger war ja auch nicht groß ne also das relativ kleine teile.
Ja die waren nicht schwerer als eins komma zwei eins komma fünf kilogramm also je rover das ist natürlich,
ich würde sagen ein zehntel von dem was messgeräte sozusagen wiegt und auch vielleicht unterzubringen dann von der masse.
Kostet immer noch geld so ein kilo hochzukriegen aber im rahmen der gesamtkosten fällt es halt nicht mehr weiter ins gewicht,
was hat man denn jetzt für erkenntnisse bekommen weil ich denke mal wenn sie jetzt hier mit ihrem team sitzen man,
die anspannung dürfte ja dann wirklich täglich steigen so also erstmal man kommt an klar dass er nach jahren,
man arbeitet jetzt jahrelang hinter auf so einen so einen moment und dann dann dann findet das auf einmal statt so da fängt man ja wahrscheinlich schon mal an leichte erregung anzeichen von sich zu geben aber man weiß ja dann auch okay jetzt.
Ab jetzt kommen neue daten und die müssen ja eigentlich am laufenden meter mit unseren bisherigen annahmen.
Abgeglichen werden stimmt das passt das noch sind wir immer noch im selben
rahmen unserer berechnung gibt es irgendwelche grundsätzlichen erkenntnisse dass es vielleicht irgendwas komplett anders als als wir gedacht haben,
haben dann diese also die ersten daten kam natürlich auf jeden fall erstmal vom vom satelliten selber als vom mutterschiff haben dann die länder auch,
interessantes geliefert oder war das dann eher schon nicht so relevant.
Für die,
bilder gesehen haben zum ersten mal waren wir doch schon sehr schockiert weil wir haben riesige steine gesehen die auch sehr.
Uneben waren jedoch wussten wir auch nicht und das konnte man auch
bis zu diesem punkt noch nicht wissen wie groß diese steine waren weil
man muss natürlich entsprechend auch referenzpunkt haben um zu wissen wie man sozusagen die bilder,
wie man sozusagen die messungen dann festlegen kann bei minerva war das am anfang auch schwierig ich glaube inzwischen haben die kollegen natürlich
daten ausgewertet aber zwischen der minerva separation und der messgerät separation des fahren ja höchstens zehn tage glaube ich
einundzwanzigster september bei minerva und dritter oktober war war schon da hatten wir natürlich gar keine zeit um
irgendwie daraus dann wirklich relevante daten dann für uns zu generieren somit haben wir dann mit den orbit daten vor allem mit dem mutterschiff daten gearbeitet
und
es war schwierig da eine landesstelle zu finden weil was wir auf jeden fall vermeiden wollten ist das messgerät.
Irgendwie und die gefahr war groß wenn man sich die oberfläche bilder angeschaut hat es war steinig es war zerklüft,
wenn so eingekeilt zwischen zwei steinen liegen sollte da hätte glaube ich.
Mobilitätsverlustes hätte es nicht geschafft den ländern herauszubekommen und eines unserer referenz information waren dass aufgrund von der
von der größe des landes und von den größen verteilung der gesteine auf der oberfläche wir doch.
Bitte steine vermeiden sollen die so um die fünfzig zentimeter sind und die mehr oder weniger mehrere,
zentimeter bis zu fünfzig zentimeter so voneinander liegen entfernt liegen,
das ist schwierig weil man nämlich gar nicht weiß sind die steine die wir sehen ist das wirklich fünfzig zentimeter was wir da aussehen mit der auflösung die die bilder des mutterschiffs sozusagen uns geliefert hat ist das wirklich.
Ist das vorhin steine wirklich nur fünfzig zentimeter ist oder sehen wir nur den oberen teil und da drunter sieht es wiederum ganz anders aus,
des eisbergs sozusagen solche informationen konnten wir natürlich nicht extrahieren,
das ist eine ungewissheit mit der wir sozusagen bei unserer vorbereitung mehr oder weniger leben mussten und sagen müssen okay,
haben wir die daten die wir haben und wir müssen so eine art risiko abschätzung machen und für uns selber dann schauen wie groß ist denn das risiko,
das stecken bleibt und zu zu anderen risiken sind ja noch andere da.
Man muss vielleicht mal was.
Nochmal dazu sagen wie diese länder jetzt eigentlich alle ausgestattet waren also waren natürlich sehr unterschiedlich die minerva eins hatten nur kameras und ein thermometer.
Also es war wirklich so kann bilder machen und weiß wie kalt es ist so dass auf jeden fall schon mal eine interessante information,
und der minerva zwei waren glaube ich ähnlich aber hatte zumindest schon mal so noch so ein beschleunigungssensor und konnte auch staub detektieren.
Und wieso mit leds hat aber glaube ich kein gesehen aber was jetzt,
und die dem mascara auch vereint ist,
alle also weil wir sagen die rover,
aber das ist ja nicht so ein rover im sinne von fahrzeug mit rädern was über die oberfläche fährt sondern alle hatten sozusagen dieses prinzip eines.
Hüpf mechanismus.
Hüpfen es genau also mit so einem schwungrad die im,
im körper im gerät selber drin war also quasi ein einfacher drehmoment tor und das schwungrad dreht man auf so eine magische art und weise holt quasi so einmal schwung,
und dann konnten die hüpfen und sind die dann auch gehüpft.
Sie sind gehüpft alle.
Alle sind gehüpft.
Alle sind gehüpft und minerva eines der minerva du richtig weit sogar also natürlich nicht in einem sprung aber anscheinend ist es wirklich schon also über,
mehrere kilometer hinaus ist es anscheinend über die oberfläche hat er sich fortbewegt.
Weil sie einfach immer so gehüpft in so zehn fünfzehn meter springen oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht ob es zehn oder fünfzehn meter waren in einem sprung oder ob es mehrere kleine sind aber dadurch dass die minerva rovers länger lebt,
als der maske länder war es für sie natürlich einfacher sequenzielle sozusagen sich dann weiter und weiter sich fortzubewegen.
Die energieversorgung war ja irgendwie also die die lova seminar was die hatten ja glaube ich solarzellen und eine zumindest der zweite nicht.
Also die ersten zwei ja beide.
Also die eins eins eins.
Eins eins.
Messgerät hat aber sowas nicht.
Nein messgerät hatte keine solarzellen die dann zu einer aufladung der batterien geführt hat,
metzger that solarzellen aber das haben wir also nur einzelne die das waren das war ein zug system des gesamten systems,
die sonneneinstrahlung sozusagen festzustellen und entsprechend dann als redundanz prinzip dann für die lage regelung des lenders.
Wo kann man die energie her.
Die kamen von batterien und zwar von nicht aufladbar batterien.
Ja aber wir halten nicht aufladbar batterien ihre spannung über mehrere jahre weltall.
Man muss sich sehr kühl lagern.
Okay das ist noch relativ einfach.
Ja das ist sehr einfach man darf man sollte versuchen ein design zu finden so dass die batterien sich nicht entladen und was wir dann natürlich auch gemacht,
dass wir dann vor der landung dann die batterien,
passivieren mussten natürlich weil wir ja diese schicht bekommen aufgrund von der langen lagerung der batterien um die batterien wieder frei zu bekommen aber,
die batterien die wir eingesetzt haben die haben letztendlich auch die lebensdauer dann erlaubt die wir berechnet haben wir haben für,
circa stunden,
lebensdauer haben wir die batterien ausgelegt indem wir natürlich auch die flugphase mit berechnet haben und,
es ist auch so rausgekommen also der länder hat ja siebzehn stunden überlebt.
Hm
Warum nicht mehr also warum sechzehn stunden klingt jetzt ja nicht besonders viel wenn man jahrelang unterwegs ist und dann hat man nur so einen schuss und dann dann ist nach einem tag schon wieder alles vorbei,
gab es wenig hoffnung noch mehr erkenntnisse zu haben wenn man länger im betrieb ist oder warum weil man damit zufrieden.
Zufrieden waren wir natürlich nicht damit wir hätten viel lieber wenn maske länger gelebt hätte aber es waren einfach die umstände die,
dieses design dann getrieben hat zum beispiel die baugröße es ist ja nicht groß
der länder das heißt wir könnten nicht sehr viel an batterien unterbringen und die masse ist ja auch nicht groß zehn kilogramm drei kilogramm alleine gehen schon für die wissenschaftliche nutzlasten weg
das heißt wir haben nur noch sieben kilogramm übrig gehabt um dann sämtliche,
andere sub systeme wie kommunikation und wie,
kontrolle system schwung und auch die,
die ganzen wieder,
energie verteilungsschlüssel dass das in all diese dinge die dann untergebracht werden und das ist da ist nicht mehr so viel übrig die struktur selber müssen wir ja auch noch berücksichtigen und
davon also das zusammen dann sieben kilo da hatten wir nicht
so viel mehr an masse aber wir haben uns neben diesen strikten anforderungen die uns dann gegeben wurde
auch eine art risikobewertung gemacht und.
Wir wiederaufladbare batterien genommen dann hätte es sich das design ändern müssen weil wir,
dann noch mehr fläche gebraucht und diese fläche hätten wir nur dadurch ermöglichen können dass wir ein solarpanels noch zusätzlich drauf montiert hätten und es dann aufgeklappt,
hätten das abgesehen davon dass das dann wiederum schwierig ist für die mobilität,
das bedeutet dass wir dann die panele wieder zuklappen müssen um dann zu springen kommt natürlich die gefahr hinzu dass der mechanismus vielleicht gar nicht klappt,
vielleicht weil es einfach viel komplizierter ist.
Das ist so eine einfache batterie wo einfach strom drin ist und anschalten und fertig.
Das war sozusagen besser es war die erste mission mit so einem größeren länder sozusagen auf einem asteroiden zu landen und,
da haben wir dann gemeint wir wollten das design so einfach wie möglich machen auch wenn das dann gegen eine längere betriebsleiter zeit spricht aber es garantiert uns zumindestens sechzehn stunden,
und man.
Hat man ja auch gesehen bei filet bei der rosetta mission da ist es ja im prinzip schief gegangen
da ist genau das passiert was ja eigentlich auch vermeiden wollten man ist in so einer blöden spalte gelandet weil halt beim aufsetzen
alles ja,
alle geplanten halte maßnahmen sozusagen alle nicht funktioniert haben das ding hüpfte dann mehr oder weniger unkontrolliert über den kometen und ist dann in irgendeiner dusseligen spalte hängen geblieben wo dann halt die sonneneinstrahlung so schlecht war,
dass eben kein strom mehr generiert werden konnte und dann gab es noch ein paar hilferuf und das war's.
Und das war's ja so ist das und ich meine dass wir das entwickelt haben oder konzipiert haben da,
war die landung von vielen natürlich noch etwas weit
aber uns war es es war uns schon bewusst dass solche dinge passieren können das messgerät in einer
lampen könnte wo wirklich gar keine sonneneinstrahlung passiert und dann mit so einer geringen masse dann sozusagen das lebenserhaltungssystem dann aufzubauen das war uns wiederum viel zu risikoreich.
Ok aber
dass die spalte war natürlich dann trotzdem noch eine gefahr gar nicht mal wegen mangelnder sonneneinstrahlung soll weil man hätte sich ja auch vorstellen können dass man so zwischen zwei steine eingeklemmt ist wo dann diese schwungrad technik so nicht mehr funktioniert.
Weil die bewegung ja nur funktioniert wenn auch raum da ist.
Wenn ein raum da ist und auch weil es nur begrenzt ist in seinem freiheitsgrade weil wir haben natürlich ein schwungrad wenn man sich anschaut als xy,
koordinatensystem dann schwingt sozusagen dass der schwung sozusagen in entlang der,
ebene das heißt die.
Ebene könnte man ja gar nicht beeinflussen wir haben natürlich aufgrund von unseren simulationen herausgefunden dass dadurch dass das ist wiederum der vorteil wenn man kein.
Ebenen asteroiden hat dass gerade diese unebenheit natürlich die mobilität begünstigt das ist immer irgendwie ein schwung gibt so ein drall gibt der den länder aufrichten wird und,
das ist wiederum der vorteil davon aber dadurch dass wir eben nicht diese zwei ebenen,
aufrichten konnten wäre das stecken bleiben sozusagen das ungünstige stecken bleiben natürlich ja,
nicht vom vorteil gewesen in dem moment.
Dann gehen wir noch mal genau in diesen,
sechzehn beziehungsweise siebzehn stunden slot rein also nachdem die anderen rover jetzt alle schon ihren spaß hatten und fleißig da auf dem,
asteroiden rumgehüpft sind hieß es dann irgendwann so okay jetzt dürft ihr auch mitspielen,
da wird ja sicherlich irgendeine detailabstimmung dann gegeben haben wie bereitet man sich denn bitte auch auf auf sechzehn stunden mission vor weil,
man braucht ja dann vielleicht auch irgendwann mal eine mütze schlaf und ist ja auch nicht so dass man jetzt in der ersten minute aufsteht anschaut,
wieder ins bett geht,
das klingt für mich ja schon eher so dass um zweiunddreißig stunden tag den man da hat wie wie wie geht man denn da allein human du geistig rand.
Wir hatten schichten
eingeplant wir haben schichten eingeplant also in dem sozusagen dann die jeweiligen kollegen da sind und auch
entsprechend dann auch aussagekräftig sind das heißt zum beispiel war uns klar dass für das power system wenn die batterien eigenschaft
angeschaut werden dass dann da auch immer dann zwei experten da sind die sich das dann teilen also von der schicht her.
Ich muss aber auch zugeben so richtig schlafen konnte weder ich noch die kollegen nicht das heißt dann haben wir es uns trotzdem von der ferne angeschaut,
ferne und es ist ja auch dass man arbeitet schon seit jahren
daran da kann man auch in dem moment gar nicht schlafen irgendwann mal glaube ich auch im im laufe dieser siebzehn stunden waren die nerven auch manchmal dünn,
ja und,
aber trotz allem hat man sich zusammengerissen um da dann auch die richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen.
Eine entscheidung die vorher getroffen werden musste ist wo,
geht es denn eigentlich hin also das ding hatte ja dann auch glaube ich diesen kilometer durchmesser von dem man vorher ausgegangen ist also das hat soweit gepasst und war ja trotz dieser diamanten struktur eher,
ja so ein typischer wie man sich so wie man sich früher wie man den achtziger jahren schon gespielt hat so so sah das ding irgendwie im prinzip auch aus also so eher rund nicht wirklich eine kugel aber halt irgendwie jetzt auch nicht so eine so eine lange flunder oder irgendwie
sowas und,
dann gab es die ganzen kamera bilder die gravitations messung etcetera und da muss man erst mal in so einem diskurs gehen wo will man jetzt eigentlich hin und wo kann man denn überhaupt hin als hätte man in prinzip an jedem beliebigen ort gekonnt.
Nein wir durften es nicht weil wir,
dann die annahme des mutterschiffs nämlich auch.
Muss ja noch platz freigelassen werden.
Also platz ist es weniger sondern es liegt daran dass auf der oberfläche weiß lackiert ist und das liegt daran dass wir das thermisch machen mussten.
Um sozusagen die abstrahlen der der wärme sozusagen zu optimieren aber auch.
Die wärme der sonne oder die wärme.
Die sonneneinstrahlung der sonne und dann aber auch des gerätes das musste dann entsprechend dann optimiert werden und wir haben dann eine weiße lackierung genommen und diese weiße lackierung ist natürlich dann auch,
wunderbar wenn es darum geht dann mit den kameras des mutterschiffs sozusagen den ländern wiederzufinden das ist natürlich etwas einfacher,
aber dadurch dass bücher zu weit für ihre annäherungsversuch auch target markus,
benutzt es handelt sich hier um reflektierende bälle die sie dann vorher auf die oberfläche schmeißen,
anhand derer see dann sozusagen ihre navigation dann abspielen ist es so dass wir ein messgerät zu nahe wäre
dass dann die busters
mit den target marketers verwechseln könnte und das war eine gefahr dann für zwei und entsprechend gab es auch regionen die waren für meeske tabu,
da durften wir nicht lange.
Ok wie viel bleibt dann noch übrig von der rest fläche.
Gott sei dank genug dass wir bis zu zehn möglichen kandidaten gekommen sind.
Ok wie geht man dann davor dann kommt wir dieser krieg zwischen technikern und und wissenschaftlern.
Dann kommt der krieg wobei das beim sc war es einfacher,
weil missgeburt hatte so viele wichtige forderungen technisch,
auf technischer seite gesehen dass die wissenschaftler das auch akzeptieren mussten weil sonst hätten sie ja ihre daten eigentlich bekommen und eines dieser war dass wir eben nur sechzehn stunden haben und wir so
lampen müssen oder auf der stelle landen müssen so dass wir die beste kommunikation,
haben und das hat was mit dem tag nachtsyndrom plus zu tun das heißt wir durften entweder nicht zu sehr im norden landen oder auch nicht zu sehr im süden weil dann wir wollten etwas haben was sozusagen einen guten tag nach zyklus hat,
dann eine andere sache die auch sehr.
Was für eine rotationsgeschwindigkeit hatte diese astrid eigentlich.
Der routinierte mit sieben komma sechs stunden um sich herum.
Quasi in diesen sechzehn stunden war zwei rotationen.
Zwei rotationen mitgezählt und dann eine andere sache war auch die thermischen.
Und man wollte jetzt viel tag haben also man wollte die sonne immer dabei haben oder eher nicht also es ist die sonne jetzt eher hinderlich oder eher hilfreich.
Sonne wir brauchen die sonne und kommunizieren und das heißt wir müssen dann so viel wie möglich an tag haben.
Warum braucht man die sonne zum kommunizieren.
Weil haie boostet sei nämlich nur auf haie booster zwei sind nur auf der sonnenseite immer gerichtet,
weil haie busse zwei der orbit von high,
selber auch noch licht brauch von der sonne das heißt heir busse zwei hatte immer die sonne im rücken und die konstellation war entsprechend immer so dass wir dann immer nur mit dem mutterschiff kommuniziert haben wenn tag ist.
Okay verstehe.
Sobald es nacht war gab es dann gar keine kommunikation und.
Also möchte man irgendwohin wo möglichst viel tag ist.
Aber auch wiederum nicht zu viel weil mit viel tag verbunden ist auch dann vielleicht,
thermischer verhalten,
der oberfläche dass der da die stelle sich dann viel mehr aufwärmt und das wäre auch nicht gut für unsere messgerät länder weil dann hätte sich dann der länder aufgeheizt.
Wie weit waren wir eigentlich von der sonne weg zu dem zeitpunkt also wo hat sich das ganze abgespielt als wirklich das rentenniveau stattgefunden hat.
Das muss ich schauen aber ich glaube wir waren.
Wie zwischen erde und maß oder,
okay also so anderthalb so das heißt so von den temperaturen ist schon noch so vergleichbar quasi mit dem was auch bei der erde an energie ankommt ist es etwas weniger,
aber es ist jetzt nicht wie jupiter oder neptun wo es irgendwie nur noch kalt ist sondern daher stand sozusagen auch eine gewisse hitze sprich wenn die sonne da drauf knallt dann passiert auch.
Dann ist es schon wer warm genau und es ist auch so dass die ja so klein ist und das thema control system auch entsprechend optimiert wurde für einen bestimmten temperaturbereich,
und man hat ja aufgrund von von dieser enge an instrumenten ist auch die,
die interaktion der instrumente miteinander auch ganz anders als wenn man einen etwas größeren länder hat
und wir mussten das berücksichtigen gerade für die wissenschaftliche nutzlasten und darf es nicht zu warm werden weil dann das signal zu rausch verhältnis natürlich dann schlechter wird,
und für die batterien ist es so dass die batterien optimal bei zwanzig grad dann arbeiten.
Man entsprechend dann auch diese zwanzig grad halten muss.
Okay das heißt wir haben jetzt hier schon schon den ganzen blumenstrauß an an anforderungen viktor da muss irgendwie genug sich kontakt sein das sitzt sonne voraus die macht aber warm es darf dann auch nicht
zu warm werden es darf auch nicht zu kalt werden
und dann hat man quasi so eine software da wirft man das alles rein und dann auf einmal schaut man quasi auch so ein modell dieses asteroiden wo ja wahrscheinlich dann farbliche markierungen sind wie optimal
bestimmte bereiche jetzt wäre und am schluss bleiben so ein paar übrig und dann sagt man so okay jetzt dürften die wissenschaftler jetzt könnt ihr euch noch mal was aus.
Könnt ihr euch mal was aussuchen.
Aber drei vorschläge für euch so soviel war's ja wahrscheinlich.
Also es waren zehn es waren zehn die noch in dem bereich sind aber sie wurden dann reduziert auf zwei.
Und dann spielte dann natürlich dann auch wiederum es ist natürlich ein unterschied wenn wir jetzt zu den,
missions analytiker sagen also es ist uns,
wenn die genauigkeit der berechnung des des landes bereichs etwa um die zweihundert meter ist zum beispiel und wir,
tieren dann eine kommunikation länge die ist am tag zwischen drei stunden
rund vier stunden und dann sieht man dann auch dass je nach landesstelle es dann vielleicht drei komma vier stunden sind oder,
drei stunden sind dann muss man das natürlich auch auswerten man muss sich das anschauen manchmal zählen ja selbst zwanzig minuten kommen
kommunikation viel mehr,
als als andere aspekte und das ist ein das ist eben diese auswertung diese abschätzung inwieweit wir sozusagen an marvin haben im system mit der landesstelle.
Welche datenmengen hat das gerät so im idealfall aufzeichnen können so im verhältnis zu dem was was hoch gesendet werden konnte.
Wir hatten insgesamt am ende jetzt muss ich schauen.
Weil es ja sozusagen jetzt kommen die ganzen sensoren dazu also ist richtig sehe ist ja eine nochmal eine kamera an bord gewesen bei mascot so eine weitwinkelkamera es gab nochmal ein spektrometer.
Frau roth spektrometer stimmt das ja genau und man newtonmeter und ein radio meter.
Und ein radio meter.
Das radio meter das hat radio gehört.
Das hat die thermischen wellenlängen sozusagen untersucht und dadurch dann die ähm die temperatur eigenschaften des asteroiden bestimmt.
Das wäre hätte ich ja jetzt eher vom infrarot spektrometer aber das ist eher zur zur bestimmung der.
Der zusammensetzung der mineral logie genau aus es arbeitet im infrarotbereich weil die mineral mineralöle sind in diesem bereich,
also vom spektrum her,
haben sie dort ihre markierungen genau also messgerät hat insgesamt achtzig megabyte an daten.
Zusammengetragen in.
Zusammengetragen ja.
Und die mussten ja dann sozusagen auch hoch.
Die müssen alle hochkommen.
Wie groß war dann der abstand zum zum zum mutterschiff in dem moment.
Der abstand zu immer in einer distanz von zwanzig,
kilometern geflogen aber für messi haben sie sich auf eine höhe von zwei bis drei kilometer äh haben sie sich dann ähm.
Abgesenkt um um diese kommunikation zu.
Um die kommunikation zu erleichtern genau also während der operation von messgerät war booster zwischen drei,
zwei drei kilometer vom asteroiden entfernt.
Und es hat aber auch gut funktioniert.
Das hat sehr gut funktioniert
die daten sind auch sehr sehr schnell wieder zu erde zurückgekommen und unsere kollegen also auch hier mein dank an sie sie haben wirklich die daten uns so schnell wie möglich zur verfügung gestellt,
und das hat uns sehr gut sehr geholfen.
Die mussten ja dann auch erstmal wieder zurückkommen.
Genau ja ein trip time oder die signal umlauf zeit zuzusagen beträgt ja dreißig minuten circa als maske gelandet ist also hin und zurück.
Also vom vom satelliten zur erde und.
Von erde zum satelliten und dann zurück ja.
Also diese diese auswahl des landes ortes war dann auch glücklich gewählt.
Also wenn man jetzt mal den moment mal des,
knopfdruck quasi der ja natürlich nicht einen knopfdruck ist sondern man sagt okay dann und dann geht's los und dann weiß man es auch erst eine viertelstunde später ob's geklappt hat.
Das wird dann sozusagen gemeinsam mit dem team des mutterschiffs ausgerechnet festgelegt etcetera was wurde dann gelöst damit damit der länder auch wirklich das schiff verlässt.
Also gelöst wird es durch ein signal das heir busse zwei losschickt und dadurch wird ein,
ein draht getrennt und durch die abtrennung des drahtes welches teil unseres separations-vorschau ist,
ein aktuator initiiert der,
sich dann löst und er schiebt dann unsere separations-vorschau hatte von dem hayabusa zwei mutterschiff weg,
und dadurch wird auch messgerät aus dieser charity aus dieser interface zwischen
dem länder und dem mutterschiff dann heraus geschoben ganz langsam mit einer geschwindigkeit von circa drei zentimeter bis fünf zentimeter pro sekunde und
dann geht der länder dann in diesen ballistischen abfall flug über.
Also ich glaube bei bei bei rosetta und viele war das eine schraube die dann gedreht wurde um.
Gedreht wurde genau.
So macht man das auch.
Das ist ähnlich ja genau.
Also man schraubt sich quasi einfach in einer bestimmten geschwindigkeit heraus und dadurch.
Kann man natürlich dann erstmal auch sehr genau sagen weil man ist wirklich losgelassen hat und man erstellt damit dann auch eben die gewünschte geschwindigkeit automatisch auch her.
Okay ich glaube ich muss gerade mal nachgerechnet also für diese achtzig megabyte wenn man sechzehn stunden.
Sechzehn stunden lang zeit hat zu senden aber er hat ja wahrscheinlich die ganze zeit gesendet ne von diesen sechzehn stunden konnte ja nur die hälfte gesendet werden,
ungefähr naja auf jeden fall braucht man so zwanzig kilo bitte pro sekunde datenraten um das irgendwie runter zu bekommen so jetzt schwebt das ding also herunter und,
fällt dann auf die stelle runter und es ist halt wirklich so als ob ich jetzt einen schuhkarton aus dem fenster raus schmeißen nur in zeitlupe.
Tritt trifft dann irgendwie auf der war dann wahrscheinlich,
na ja klar war der stabil gebaut aber es gab jetzt keinerlei lande füße oder sonst irgendwas hat halt einfach drauf geworfen und dann ist es irgendwie liegen geblieben,
und dann.
Kommt wahrscheinlich erstmal das große fragezeichen okay was jetzt passiert und man kriegt daten von dem länder der sagt ich liege jetzt wahrscheinlich.
So schräg oder das kamerabilder also welche sensoren also woraus gewinnt man sozusagen jetzt eine information wo man ist wie man ist.
Sensoren die die lage des landes bestimmen,
es handelt sich hierbei um wir nennen es optiker proxima um led licht welches ausgesendet wird und dann wieder im idealfall zurück,
wenn der länder dann auf einer bestimmten oberfläche liegt oder wenn er ihm leeren bereich liegt je nachdem welche
fläche das aussendet dass wir dann zurück reflektiert und dann werden die signale bestimmt und dadurch dass diese ops an fünf seiten des lenders befestigt sind kann man das aus den daten dann feststellen ob
messgerät richtig oder falsch liegt,
richtig oder falsch liegt da die definition liegt darin ob die kamera und das radio meter auf dem boden zeigen und das mikroskop auch,
auf dem boden zeigt das ist für uns die richtige lage für den länder wenn es geht dann fällt es runter wie sie gesagt haben ballistisch dann gibt es eine art
bauen zink fase so eine art aufprall phase deren länge wir theoretisch zu simulieren können,
aber nicht wirklich bestimmen können.
Hängt davon ab wo man jetzt einen stein trifft und wie man fällt.
Oder auch wie die oberfläche des asteroiden weicher ist es härter je nachdem kann es entweder bis zu fünfundvierzig minuten haben wir ausgerechnet
dauern oder im idealfall bei maske letztendlich glaube ich schon nach zehn fünfzehn minuten lager wieder sozusagen.
Fast eine viertel stunde rumgehüpft quasi bis er sich richtig beruhigt hat.
Richtig beruhigt hat bis er sich richtig beruhigt hat.
Ohne dass er jetzt also der hat auch nicht automatisch schon das schwungrad irgendwie zum einsatz gebracht um auf eine bestimmte also ist einfach erstmal nur runter gefallen und hüpft nicht mehr.
Ist dann hüpft nicht mehr und dieses ich hüpfe nicht mehr signal und,
ich schaue mir an in welcher lage ich mich befinde wird dann an den bordcomputer gesendet der verarbeitet da und wir haben auf messgerät eine art autonomie,
das ist eine sehr simple autonomie die den länder dann bewegen soll dann entweder das schwungrad,
zu animieren und zu sagen okay ich liege falsch also begib dich vielleicht in die richtige position oder wenn der länder in der richtigen position ist zu sagen okay jetzt liegst du richtig jetzt kannst du anfangen mit den wissenschaftlichen messungen,
das ist so eine art zustands automat ja,
falsch ja richtig oder nein falsch und dann entsprechend wird dann der algorithmus initiiert um den länder dann entweder in die richtige lage zu bringen oder dann die messungen zu beginnen.
War das erforderlich.
Das war erforderlich weil wir wollten wir hatten ja nur.
Ich meine war es konkret auch erfolgreich also ist er auf der richtigen oder auf der falschen seite gelandet.
Das war ein krimi an sich wir gehen davon aus aus den daten die wir haben dass er auf der falschen seite gelandet ist dann das auch richtig detektiert hat.
Dass wir mit dem butterbrot eigentlich ne also es selbstverständlich landet man mit der butter auf den boden.
Immer auch auf dem asteroiden.
Wissenschaftlich erwiesen.
Auf der erde oder auf dem asteroiden und dann kam es auch zum aufrichten mechanismus und,
dann haben die sensoren die signale wieder zurückgegeben,
an den bordcomputer und der on bordcomputer oder der algorithmus hat die signale als wir sind jetzt in der richtigen position fange an zu messen interpretiert.
Wie cool bleibt man in dem moment wo man so ein signal kriegt.
Also ich würde sagen cool ist
falsch ich war erleichtert und ich glaube die meisten von uns man erleichtert in dem moment als der länder sozusagen dann auf dem boden dann die ersten signale zurückgeschickt.
Weil es ja nicht nur die botschaft das hat das irgendwie alles okay ist oder nicht kaputt ist und es ist ja auch dieses.
Das hat er tatsächlich funktioniert so alles was man sich vorher gedacht hat eine eventualitäten konnte man irgendwie ausgleichen es ist dabei nichts schief gegangen,
und man ist jetzt eigentlich so völlig im modus also man,
es ist ja im prinzip keine zeit verloren wurden die maximal denkbare bereitstellungsraum zeit sozusagen also wenn man nur sechzehn stunden hat will man ja jetzt nicht auch erstmal
vier stunden damit verbringen ding erstmal in die richtige stelle zu bringen sondern er lag eigentlich schon.
Dann,
bei dem zweiten aufrichten mechanismus anscheinend in der richtigen in der richtigen lage aber es hat uns dann im verlaufe der zeit noch ein bisschen stutzig gemacht weil messgerät hat ja zwei antennen,
zur redundanz das eine ist auf der oberfläche installiert die eine antenne und dann also die top-platz antenne und die bodenplatte antenne.
Das egal wie man jetzt liegt.
Dass er immer sozusagen funken kann das ist die drin und dann prinzip dahinter und da haben wir aber gemerkt dass die antennen,
also mit mehr oder einfach gesagt die falsche antenne hat stärker funktioniert als sie richtige antenne,
das hat uns schon stutzig gemacht und,
wir wussten auch nicht ist es jetzt muss es so sein oder muss es nicht so sein und wir haben uns lange überlegt,
das ganze diskutiert aber auch die jeans sensoren haben wir aber festgestellt dass das signal ein bisschen flach war.
Durch die ganzen hauskeeping die daten die darunter gekommen sind ähm.
Das hat er uns stutzig gemacht aber wir konnten uns noch,
also wir hatten gedacht irgendwie kann es passieren dass doch der länder in der falschen position ist und schon jetzt angefangen hat seine wissenschaftlichen instrumente anzuschalten,
da hat die jacke dann sehr schnell die kamera taten,
uns geschickt und auch die daten des mikroskop und die haben wirklich dann festgestellt dass da streu lichter reingekommen ist und es gibt auf der falschen seite leer das heißt dass bei dem,
ersten aufrichten manöver,
signale sozusagen richtig interpretiert worden er sich aufgerichtet hat aber wieder in die falsche richtung gekommen ist aber er dachte er wäre richtig.
Hat angefangen zu messen genau.
Ok also doch alles gar nicht so einfach.
Es ist nicht einfach.
In dem moment okay streusel wo kommt das her.
Die sonne die kamera lag.
Verstehe und dann hat sie sich einfach geirrt weil es ist ja auch verdammt hell also man denkt ja dann immer so dunkel aber da ist kein nebel da sind keine wolken da knallt die sonne dann,
voll rein und das ist ein problem mir ging's,
dann weiter also man lag jetzt richtig jetzt konnten einfach daten gesammelt werden dann hüpft man es erstmal nicht weiter durch die gegend oder also jetzt muss es muss man ja auch entscheiden so okay was machen wir jetzt,
guter masterplan gegeben haben aber jetzt ist ja die ist-situation erreicht worum ging es denn jetzt erstmal.
Also es ging erst mal darum den länder in die richtige position zu versetzen das.
Aber das war ja jetzt.
Nein er weiß eben nicht er war ja sozusagen nicht und musste jetzt in die.
Also man muss ja stimmt ja man muss jetzt nochmal korrigieren ok das heißt jetzt muss man nochmal schwung holen.
Genau er er ist ja in der annahme dass er in der richtigen position liegt es war aber.
Die autonomie hat sich in dem moment einfach abgeschaltet hat gesagt wieso was wollt ihr eigentlich.
Was wollt ihr denn genau ist doch alles super jetzt fahre ich meine sequenzen schön brav durch und dann wenn die sequenzen also der ganze sciences vorbei ist dann heißt es ja das nächste ist ich springe nochmal und messe wo an.
Verstehe das heißt man muss jetzt erstmal zwischen reingehen sagen moment du hast leider knick in der optik.
Genau und das ist natürlich auch mit zeitverzug verbunden wieder dreißig minuten hin und zurück sozusagen um dann,
ja und es ist letztendlich haben wir die autonomie haben wir dann unterwandert,
wir haben den länder gesagt jetzt hör auf autonom zu arbeiten jetzt höre auf uns beende erstmal den zyklus so schnell wie möglich und richte dich nochmal auf.
Das hat der länder dann auch gemacht das heißt es war ground command,
von der erde aus und dann hieß es wieder vom von maske ja ich liege jetzt richtig jetzt fange ich an zum essen wieder.
Also richte dich auf heißt ja eigentlich nur mach spielereien mit dem schwung.
Schwung genau schwing deinen arm und bewege dich wieder.
So schwingt dann irgendwie wie läuft denn das eigentlich also der der rotiert ja nicht einfach nur sondern man rotiert in die eine richtung und dann unterbricht man die rotation für einen kurzen moment oder so und dann und dann ich denke mal so oh jetzt müsste.
Impuls in das system und dadurch dass wir so wenig gravitation auf dem asteroiden haben wir haben ja,
zu einem zehntausende von der erde.
Ein zehntausend okay.
Genau,
wird natürlich der impuls dann in diesen hüpf mechanismus in diesen dann übertragen und dadurch bewegt sich dann der astrid sich fort und auch da haben wir natürlich.
Der länder nicht ein astrid der bleibt ja hoffentlich vorher ist.
Ach gott der schuldige der astro.
Okay also ergibt sich quasi selber so einen ruck und weil ihnen eben der astrid nicht nennenswert festhält schwimm wirbelt er sozusagen aber es,
keine klare vorberechnet e also man berechnet jetzt diesen schwung nicht vor dass man,
genau auf der anderen seite landet weil man weiß ja auch nicht so genau wo man dann sonst eher würfeln.
Es ist ein würfeln.
Man hat so einen würfel mit zwei seiten und man würfelt ihn immer wieder und die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man irgendwann auch mal wieder auf der richtigen seite landet steigt.
Hast du beim ersten mal schon funktioniert.
Es hat dann funktioniert.
Beim ersten mal auch.
Beim ersten mal ja nicht.
Bei der beim ersten mal den.
Nach dem nach.
Man festgestellt hat dass es dass er falsch geguckt hat.
Ja das hat funktioniert dann ja also die er hat gemessen aber auch da müssen wir natürlich erst mal feststellen ob das die daten.
Wieder streubt sich dabei ist.
Nicht streut oder ob er wieder mit den jeans entsorgen sich das falsch interpretiert hat und auch da müssen wir wieder abwarten aber es wird dann die ersten bilder bekommen haben von dieser asteroiden oberfläche da haben wir doch alle aufgeatmet.
Und man hat auch vor allem auch gesehen dass jetzt die richtige antenne das bessere signal hat.
Genau.
Das war ein interessanter das war wahrscheinlich so eine korrektur die so vorher noch gar nicht drin war oder also die autonomie hätte ja sagen können,
ok lage sind sogar alles schön und gut aber wenn die antenne schwächer ist dann kann das ja nicht wahr sein das war so nicht vorgesehen dass quasi der erkenntnis die erst in dem moment kam.
Die kam danach obwohl ich.
Ich denke mir dass wir verschiedene messmer zeiten eingefügt,
es ist ja so man muss sich auf ein signal verständigen und so viel auto also so intelligent ist der länder nicht dass er sozusagen eine abwägung machen kann,
sagen kann okay auf welches signal konzentriere ich mich dann eher also man kann ihm nur sagen konzentriere dich erstmal auf dieses signal das ist,
erste das primär signal das musst du interpretieren und die anderen dass sie nur sekundäre falls du ausfallen solltest wir haben uns auf unsere,
ps sensoren verständigt dass das die ersten zehn toren sind die das festlegen ja.
Danach weiß man es immer besser wo ist die künstliche intelligenz wenn man sie mal braucht.
Ja dann kommen wir doch mal zu den zu den eigentlichen daten die hier gewonnen wurden was was könnte denn jetzt von maske herausgefunden werden.
Von messgerät wurde herausgefunden dass die oberfläche des asteroiden gar kein staub hat,
wir haben ja damit gerechnet dass irgendwie staub in irgendeiner form vorhanden ist.
Also sehr leichte dünne partikel die so vielleicht auch ein bisschen rumfliegen.
Ja genau also das scheint nicht der fall zu sein dass da wirklich reguliert partikeln auf der oberfläche zu finden ist ähm.
Das heißt er ist quasi frisch gesaugt und nur stein.
Nur stein genau dann hat die kamera auch festgestellt dass es zwei arten,
von gesteine n gibt es gibt gesteinsbrocken die sind sehr kantig geschnitten und sehr scharf geschnitten und auch heller,
und es gibt wiederum die andere art von gesteine die sind ein bisschen krümelige,
sehen aus wie wie brokkoli sozusagen wie brokkoli ja sie nennen es auch colly flower structure.
Und das,
sagt auch etwas aus dann über vielleicht die entstehungsgeschichte von von rico vielleicht ist es so dass er nur einmal in seinem,
seine entstehung oder auch mehrmals durchgerüttelt wurde und dadurch dann vielleicht auch verschiedene
bereiche sozusagen aufgeschüttelt wurde ja es ist ja nicht so dass auf der oberfläche ist nur auf dieser stelle dieses gestein zu finden ist und auf der anderen stelle ist nur das also es ist wirklich alles so ineinander gemischt,
das kann aufschlüsse geben über die entstehungsgeschichte des asteroiden
was wir auch festgestellt haben ist dass der asteroid wahrscheinlich sehr porös ist und auch sehr dunkel ist.
Aber auch hart und einer der kollegen meinte es ist sowas wie braunkohle,
der ist am anfang genannt,
dunkel und porös aber hart aber dann hat er gemeint vielleicht wenn man das so bildlich sich vorstellt ist es doch eher so was wie so feste asche
sozusagen die die zusammensitzt gesetzt hat also nicht kohle mäßig sondern mehr so feste asche.
Das heißt auf einmal ist auch der übergang zwischen komet und astrid sehr viel.
Ja genau es scheint so eine art.
Ist dann ok das heißt der komet zumindest wenn man jetzt die beiden körper miteinander vergleicht ist im kern sind sie sich sehr ähnlich nur dass der komet noch irgendwas.
Was hat in der sonne im verdampft und deswegen gibt es diesen kommenden schweif.
Dann haben wir auch die temperatur messen können die temperaturverlauf auf der oberfläche des asteroiden und.
Dadurch dann auch.
Dieser tages-nachtzeit.
Die tagesform hilfreich.
Ganz hilfreich weil man will ja nicht nur messen wie warm es ist jetzt gerade sondern wie verändert sich das wie schnell kühlt es ab wie schnell wird es wieder warm.
So ist das und mit dieser temperaturverlauf kann man dann auch eine relation dann bilden gibt es da den ähnlichkeit zu dem meteoriten die wir gefunden haben auf der erde,
was auch die kollegen dann festgestellt haben an den kamera bildern auch das innen gestein ist so helle kleine punkte gibt die sie inklusions nennen und solche
einlagerung so helle mineralische
einlagerung sind auch in manchen meteoriten sammlungen wiederzufinden in und auch,
das verhalten der temperatur sozusagen des asteroiden ähnelt sehr den von bestimmten meteoriten die auf der erde gefunden wurden,
das heißt natürlich nicht dass diese meteoriten auch wirklich dann von ruhig zu stammen sondern dass es da wahrscheinlich ähnliche.
Parent bodies also.
Ja
Ursprünge geben kann.
Also das hier sozusagen aussehen aus derselben quelle mal auseinandergebrochen sind oder sich zumindest im gleichen zeitraum gebildet haben im selben bereich.
Mindestens oder im im bereich.
So die uhr tickt sechzehn stunden sind dann irgendwann rum und dann ist das ding stumm und das war's.
So ist das.
Ist das zum raumfahrt business.
So ist es.
Okay das kam jetzt zumindest nicht unerwartet aber man war der zumindest schon froh schon nochmal eine stunde rausgeholt zu haben das heißt alle einschätzungen haben auch ganz gut gestimmt und dann ist irgendwie ruhe und jetzt liegt er da rum.
Wir haben das nicht miterlebt also wir haben im team natürlich meinten wir denn es ist für uns natürlich messgerät ist so für uns natürlich wie wie,
das ist ja fast schon lebendig für uns,
das baby sozusagen da hatten wir auch dann gemeint er hat sich ja verabschiedet also er hat,
die batterien sind noch nicht ausgegangen als er noch mit uns oder der länder mit uns kommuniziert hat sondern die kommunikation ist dann abgebrochen als die nacht,
angesprochen ist und.
In der nacht.
In der nacht ist er sozusagen.
Im schlaf verschiedene.
Ja genau also das haben wir nicht erlebt ja.
Was bleibt dann,
übrig also jetzt wenn man jetzt die technische leitung hatte und das gerät ist dann irgendwie aus dann ist es ja eigentlich auch erstmal vorbei so,
aber man hat wahrscheinlich noch 'ne ganze menge daten an denen man dann noch im rückblick neue erkenntnisse gewinnen kann für künftige planungen solcher mission oder.
Ja also man hat viele daten und man denkt sich in dem moment ach jetzt würde ich es noch anders machen
und jetzt würde ich dem länder zwei schwung arme geben und man kann auch länger leben lassen wenn man das und das und das berücksichtigt natürlich also es ist sehr viel an an lessons learned
gemacht worden durch die mission wo man sagen kann okay da sind wir viel
optimierungsmöglichkeiten um solche missionen dann noch robuster zu machen oh da gibt's noch viele wissenschaftliche fragestellungen die sind interessant und die würden wir gerne auch noch
wollen ja.
Jetzt,
war natürlich die mission selber noch nicht ganz vorbei dann kam es damals schon mehrfach drüber gesprochen noch dazu dass eben seine proben genommen hat das hat also hayabusa zwei noch seine proben genommen hat das hat dann gut funktioniert.
Das hat sehr gut funktioniert sie haben zwei proben entnommen also an zwei stellen haben sie proben entnommen.
Und das war dann wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr als beim ersten mal oder.
Also es scheint so als ob es mehr ist und ja man weiß ja nur wenn man die dose geöffnet hat ja,
aber es scheint,
ob die proben entnahme sehr erfolgreich war und das interessante ist ja auch dass bei zwei die kollegen die japanischen kollegen ja einen künstlichen krater,
gemacht haben auf der oberfläche durch einen explosiven impacto und sie dann in der region dieses krater sozusagen in der nähe dann die proben entnommen haben vielleicht,
dann auch proben.
Also um mehr zu haben oder auch um tiefer zu geh.
Tiefer zu gehen man muss natürlich sich anschauen inwieweit wirklich man dann proben entnommen hat die die auch von der tiefe gekommen sind.
Das wird sich dann alles noch zeigen ich glaube ende dieses jahres ist dann die rückkehr geplant.
Also rückflug dauert jetzt quasi noch mal so ein so ein jahr.
Das sind normale solche zeiträume und der rückflug ist aber schon eingeleitet hatte ich vorhin ja schon erwähnt also seit november sie jetzt seit zwei monaten ist es zwei quasi auf dem,
rückweg dann kommt die sonne an und dann gibt's wahrscheinlich nochmal eine große party oder vom ganzen team.
Vom ganzen team ja in japan genau.
Ja
Haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen zu erwähnen auf dass man nochmal eingehen sollte also ist ja jetzt auch es gibt ja auch noch andere missionen die jetzt von anderen organisationen angestrebt werden ob ich die nasa.
Zeitgleich aus siris rex benny.
Also das ist jetzt sozusagen die sind jetzt auf den geschmack gekommen jetzt wollen sie jetzt auch.
Benötigt auch also ist ja zeitgleich mehr oder weniger an von ihre freaks besucht worden oder ist aus ihres rex ist ja noch immer bei benny wie zwei und rückruf,
das war ja schon also da,
gibt es auch intensiven austausch zwischen der jagd und der nasa kollegen wie wie die lessons learned dieser zwei mission sind und auch informationen der
jackfruit kollegen bezüglich des der ernährungsweise das ist ganz ganz wichtig auch für die andere mission wie ja,
was man da raus für erkenntnisse bekommen kann.
Ja es wird dann vor allem interessant sein zu sehen wie die wissenschaft jetzt daraus zehren kann wenn ihr innerhalb kürzester zeit von zwei solchen kohlenstoff asteroiden also von denen am meisten zu finden sind offenbar,
in unserer umgebung jetzt die daten zurückkommen und wann daraus schlüsse ziehen kann was ist da so ihre erwartungen wozu,
also es ist ja immer immer schwierig ich weiß nahezu unmöglich eigentlich vorher zu sagen was was die erkenntnisse sind man weiß es ja nicht so aber wir hatten ja am anfang so ein paar ziele formuliert so dieses mysterium wo kommt das wasser her oder wie genau,
was hat sich jetzt eigentlich aus was herausgebildet sind die asteroiden eigentlich auch nur so ein,
weiteres endprodukt oder sind sie letzten endes die zeugen der urs suppe unseres sonnensystems das sind ja im wesentlichen so die fragestellung die so im,
raum sind ich könnte mir vorstellen die kollegen vom vom drk in berlin von der planetenweg forschung die haben schon ganz feuchte finger.
Also
wenn wir jetzt auf benny und ruhig gut zu sprechen kommen dann wenn man die beiden miteinander vergleicht ist ist ja sticht es ja ins auge dass sie sich sehr ähneln das sind ja fast zwillinge
beide sind top shape asteroiden typ steroiden und wenn man sich die oberfläche anschaut dann ist es auch bemüht sehr sehr voller gesteine ähm,
der unterschied ist aber beim benny interessanterweise ist dass die nasa kollegen ja,
staub um den asteroiden herum entdeckt haben also staub welches um den asteroiden fliegt was vielleicht auf eine,
fragezeichen hindeuten.
Oder einfach nur schlecht gesaugt.
Noch schlecht getaugt ja also das ist schon sehr interessant und da kann es gab auch,
im november zweitausendundachtzehn,
vor einigen monaten gab es auch das erste meeting dazu um diese wissenschaftliche,
mal nebeneinander zu stellen und festzulegen wo ist denn da die ähnlichkeit des asteroiden und wo sind,
der beiden asteroiden wo sind da die unterschiede also so eine art vergleichende wissenschaft workshop wurde dadurch geführt also.
Ich war leider nicht dabei aber ich glaube da ist wirklich ganz viel interessantes rausgekommen.
Macht aber auch wieder schön klar,
dass er jetzt zwei getrennte missionen von zwei verschiedenen organisationen gruppen geführt wurden heißt nicht dass man da jetzt irgendwie im wettbewerb ist sondern ganz im gegenteil,
das heißt einfach man hat noch mehr daten und noch mehr vergleichsmöglichkeiten und die wissenschaftler teams die daran arbeiten arbeiten ohnehin global und arbeiten natürlich in dem moment auch zusammen an solchen sachen.
Genau ja ja also das ist etwas was in der wissenschaft welt glaube ich nicht
an dem es kein zweifel gibt das umso mehr datenbank hat umso mehr man daraus was ableiten kann und erkennen kann und da ist gerade diese zusammenarbeit auch auf internationaler ebene wird das sehr forciert.
Das macht natürlich die co-autoren liste der papers länger,
ich glaube wenn es nur das ist.
Ja vielen vielen dank für die ausführungen hier zur hayabusa zwei und natürlich vor allem zu dem aspekt des mascot lenders die wir hier erhalten haben.
Ja sehr gerne.
Und mir bleibt jetzt nicht mehr viel hinzuzufügen insofern sage ich auch vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei raum zeit bald geht's wieder weiter wie immer ich sage tschüss und bis bald.